today we're going to be speaking with
attorney mark bankston who's a partner
at farah and ball and his lead counsel
in several defamation lawsuits against
alex jones and infowars some people may
recognize him from dozens and dozens and
dozens of viral youtube videos that uh
we all looked at extensively mark great
having you on today
hey thanks for having me david so
how how did you end up uh doing these
cases and and representing a variety of
different plaintiffs here in defamation
against alex jones and infowars
i'm glad you asked me that because you
know a lot of people just start and end
with these sandy hook cases uh but the
first lawsuit i actually brought against
jones was for a young man in the boston
area who was inexplicably accused of
being the parkland shooter in the 2018
shootings in florida
and at that time i i was in touch with
this young man and
he had never even been to florida it
turned out that he was accused on 4chan
of being the parkland shooter and it was
because he was wearing a communist
themed t-shirt he had the
the comedy t-shirt that's the communist
leaders with lampshades on their heads
drinking from solo cups so visual pun on
communist party well inforce just ran
with that because they were so excited
that they could claim that the shooter
was a communist and they took this kid's
picture who was being teased on 4chan
and put it all over the world
he reached out to me and we brought suit
back in march of 2018 and when we did
that and that made national headlines uh
several sandy hook parents picked up the
phone and they said you know we've been
trying to get somebody to bring these
suits for us somebody who would take on
alex jones people were saying it's too
hard or it's too big of a fight uh we
need to find a lawyer who would do it
and i said you found one so
in in general with these types of cases
what is it you have to prove to actually
be able to
prevail in a case because it's not just
that a statement was pejorative but
there are specific
requirements that have to be met and and
do they vary state by state
they do a little bit right our common
law of defamation is as old as the magna
carta but every state has a little bit
different rules but it basically boils
down to this you have to prove three
things you have to prove that they
published a false statement
and that the second thing you have to
prove is that it was of or concerning a
specific individual and the third thing
you have to prove is that that false
statement caused them some sort of
damages
and it's it's interesting because you
know these cases actually ended up
having default judgments on the
liability but it was never really
something we needed uh it was sort of uh
you know in a lot of cases that would be
an enormous victory but in this case it
was never going to be difficult to prove
that alex jones published false
statements about these people that
caused them damages this case was always
about how much alex jones needed to be
punished when it comes to the judgment
that you obtained which made number of
headlines at close to 50 million dollars
there are state limits on what can
actually be
collected is that correct i mean what
what is it looking like will actually be
the liability for jones of the 49
million dollars
it's interesting because everyone's
talking about this right now and most of
the people who are talking about it are
not familiar with texas law
there is a punitive damage cap statute
that was passed by the legislature
however it does not apply under all
factual situations there are large
amounts of exceptions to it okay um we
are going to be moving for the entry of
judgment sometime later this week and
we'll have a hearing with the court soon
and we're very confident that those caps
aren't going to apply uh there are
several reasons why under this case and
those will be discussed at the hearing
coming up
but we believe it will be the full 50
million verdict the defendants are going
to try to argue a cap applause which
basically limits us to 750 000 in
additional damages per claim per
defendant okay there are three claims
with two defendants each that would be a
practical cap of 4.5 million at the end
of the day with costs and the interest
it would be a total verdict of about 10.
but we actually do believe that we're
going to have uh going to be able to get
around those caps with the exceptions
and that we'll be collecting the entire
50 million dollar verdict what's your
best assessment of the real financial
situation at this point of alex jones in
infowars because as many of in my
audience
know
there has been an assertion of
bankruptcy
and as the judge in your case astutely
pointed out just because you
claim bankruptcy doesn't mean you
actually are bankrupt there are some
statements i've seen from jones
basically copying to the reality that
it's a strategic move specifically to
try to limit the amount that can
actually be collected from him in this
and maybe in other cases what's your
best assessment of his financial
position
it's a real difficult question to answer
you know we had some very limited and
contradictory evidence on that at trial
and we know that his revenues are
enormous but what's harder to understand
is what's going on behind the scenes
right we have now started to encounter
some very disturbing evidence uh that is
showing mr jones has been pulling
millions and millions out of his
business after these default judgments
in fact in just just this last year
jones used his business like a cash
machine to the tune of 60 million
dollars that he removed from the company
we really don't know what is all there
um but we know there is a very
significant amount of money uh it we
feel though that by the end of all these
lawsuits you know there's there's eight
more plaintiffs up in connecticut i have
two more i'm taking to trial in a sandy
hook case plus another case with that
parkland case we're we're pretty sure
these verdicts are going to wipe him out
but actually chasing him down for that
money and the collections process may
become as interesting as the lawsuits
themselves in a case like this if
someone just
sort of like doesn't wire the money for
lack of a better term
what mechanisms are there like you know
in evictions eventually the men with
guns show up and kick you out sort of
thing right like what ultimately happens
in a case like this well if it was a
normal case and we were collecting
outside of bankruptcy we have lots of
tools at our disposal we can do a rid of
execution that essentially sends the
sheriff over to infowars and starts
seizing computers and cameras
those are the tools that you would
normally have at your disposal but this
bankruptcy proceeding is going to be
very interesting because now you're
going to have a federal bankruptcy judge
and a u.s trustee who are overseeing the
financial scrutiny of infowars that
process itself is going to be very very
dangerous for mr jones and and we're i
think by the end of all of that we're
not going to need to resort to sending
sheriffs out we think the the federal
enforcement processes in the bankruptcy
court are going to divide up the jones
empire when you say pulling money out of
businesses is that and kind of running
it through various llc's is it all
domestic do you have evidence that money
is being offshored
no you're thinking way too high level
you're thinking like that they're
sophisticated to financial operators
yeah i'm literally talking about just
money straight drawn out of the company
like it's an atm and put into jones's
hands cash 60 million cash taken out of
the company not routed through another
llc not anything like this but but
denoted on the balance sheets purely as
a member draw and jones is the only
member of free speech systems so he
really is just using the company like a
piggy bank where exactly that money went
and what happened to it is some
questions that are going to be answered
in the coming months and and
again you're talking about physical cash
i don't you know that's harder to say
that really is i i sort of don't suspect
that there was giant briefcases full of
60 million right like i have to think
that there was some sort of electronic
transfer into certain accounts what we
don't know yet is what accounts those
went to we know since that it was member
draws that that money was paid out to
alex jones but where it went from there
is very difficult to know yet
so there were all sorts of just
things that to me were unprecedented i
had never seen before like for example
that there was a running commentary on
infowars about the case as it was going
on
and then there were exhibits brought in
from during the trial which were about
the judge about the jury etc
how did you even manage this was it just
like even during the trial you needed a
team watching every minute that was
produced and broadcast
absolutely and i had one luckily uh one
stepped up is you know we're in court
all day we can't do that right um you
may be familiar with dan friesen of the
podcast knowledge fight who i would
consider maybe the world's foremost
authority on alex jones he had actually
joined on as a consulting expert pro
bono very early in the case and he and
the knowledge fight team during the days
of trial would keep track of what was
said clip out the parts that we were
interested in and provide them to us
those became exhibits in the courtroom
and it's it's really funny when you
think about it that those those things
almost get lost in the details there's
so many people talking about for
instance jones ambush on the stand about
his text messages and it almost gets
forgotten that there were videos of them
accusing the judge of pedophilia right
and saying that the trial was rigged and
that the jurors are a bunch of
blue-collar uncles who don't understand
what's going on if that had happened in
any other trial that would be the top
story that would be the headline but
there's so much that went on in this
trial that almost gets lost in the
details so the the text message thing
for people who may not have seen or
don't remember there was this incredible
situation where for days uh uh you were
sort of setting up a number of different
denials about alex jones having had text
messages specifically related to sandy
hook on his phone then it turned out you
actually had a digital copy of what was
on his phone because his attorney
accidentally as far as we know
sent that digital copy to you and this
became a huge flash point in the trial
and corporate media covered it etc first
question at any point did you think that
maybe it was a deliberate accident in
order to either try to argue for a
mistrial or in some way manipulate the
situation in their favor
i knew that it wasn't deliberate in the
sense that it was a strategy in mr
jones's favor i knew that um i will
admit that very briefly i had the same
sort of wild ideas in my head that roger
stone has been spreading the last few
days of is is andino renault an agent of
the deep state for you know used to work
at the doj for eric holder is he
screwing over alex jones some way in a
couple of seconds though you realize no
that's that's wild wild thinking the the
reality of it is is you had an attorney
who was not used to doing civil law
decided he was going to take some money
to come in and represent alex jones
purely for the fame and attention and he
was not able to protect his clients data
like he needed to those were not in my
eyes intentional moves or strategic
moves they were actually very serious
breaches of his duties to his client um
and and that just sometimes happen when
somebody's in over their head like this
there was a large uh you know an hour or
so at least that i remember
during which a number of requests were
made by alex jones counsel of the judge
when it came to that digital copy and i
don't i didn't fully grasp the the sort
of fundamentals of what it was that they
were asking for on the basis that those
doc that that record was accidentally
sent to you what was it that they were
asking for and why was it that it was
not uh granted by the judge
well it's it's funny that you say you
were having trouble figuring out what
they were asking for because so were we
okay we uh
they were asking for things that made no
sense in the context they wanted the
judge to just do a blanket sealing order
over the entire documents but they had
no basis to just suddenly seal 2.3
gigabytes of information that's not how
these rules work okay they actually had
10 days from the time of disclosure to
specifically identify any documents that
either had a legal privilege like they
were between attorney they were husband
and wife something like that or that
were confidential because they were a
trade secret or sensitive in some way
and they just didn't do it um and so
when they came into the court having
violated all the rules to do that and
then were essentially saying that that
my side had somehow acted improperly
that was quickly dismissed by the judge
she actually did give them an
opportunity to in a day
designate anything as confidential which
means that i could still have it i just
couldn't share it outside the courtroom
they actually didn't do any of that um
so the second day of those hearings the
last day of trial basically the judge
declared them free and clear they're in
my hands now is going to become some bad
news for mr jones could mr jones argue
against the ultimate judgment on the
basis that his council inadequately
represented him
interestingly no you have that option in
criminal law okay if your criminal
defense lawyer provides you an effective
assistance that is a basis for appeal
but in civil law it is not and i think
it's a good rule because i think it'd be
rare that a criminal lawyer would
intentionally throw a case because this
client's going to end up in jail but in
a civil case it could it's more
foreseeable and so we don't let
ineffective assistance be the basis of
their defense particularly in criminal
law a lot of people have appointed
counsel they can't choose who their
lawyer is mr jones got to choose this
lawyer you revealed on the young turks
last week when speaking to our friend
anna casparian that in that digital copy
there was a nude photo of alex jones
wife sent to roger stone and since then
erica wolf jones came out and said
that it was non-consensual it's not
clear to me whether she means that the
picture was taken non-consensually or
she knew about the picture but it was
not consensual to send it to roger stone
what on earth is going on when it comes
to this this is almost like a side story
but raising a ton of different questions
about the relationship between jones and
stone and just bizarre things that you
often just never even see become part of
a trial is there anything else on that
that you've since found out
i mean the only thing that i can say
that i can help clarify the record on
that is because jones is actually what i
found was interesting is after i
discussed that jones actually showed the
picture on his show
which i thought was strange um but what
i can tell you is from the nature of the
picture it was definitely consensually
taken right it wasn't it wasn't
something that he was creep shotting her
or something like that uh the the
non-consent issue comes that it was sent
apropos of nothing to roger stone and
what seems to be a bid for his attention
that was totally ignored by stone uh
just a random picture that was sent in
some other messages trying to get his
attention
as terms of what's going on in the
future with those kinds of issues
because i brought that to the fore cause
it it does look like a crime and that's
not that's not an okay thing to do oh is
that right so it would be that even if
the picture was taken consensually to
disseminate it is potentially criminal
correct and i mean there's some there's
some caveats to that in texas there has
to be basically an intent to harm or
embarrass or something like that but
sending your wife's picture to roger
stone non-consensually pretty much meets
that that definition um and so you know
i'm glad that miss wolf jones knows
about that now um and and there's a lot
of other things in those text messages
that will likely come out in due course
which raise other troubling issues in mr
jones's life um and so as that process
goes forward uh there may very well be
more revelations about what's going on
there
uh do you think i might have a
defamation case against alex jones he
did call me a predator about six months
ago because i have a paid membership
program on my show where people can pay
and get access to an extra 20 minute
show a day i can't really say that i was
damaged by it in fact it was probably
the best possible thing that's ever
happened to be honest i probably don't
have a case right no i would figure not
for a couple reasons one is you're very
much a public figure now you know uh you
are a guy involved in the middle of the
discourse and in this country we let you
be pretty reckless right up to the edge
about public figures right different
than the sandy hook parents right um but
it's also funny that i just find it
ironic that here you are talking about a
promotion program you're doing on your
your show for more content right and
here's a guy who's hawking
you know super male vitality and brain
force and he's calling you a predator
that's that's really funny to me i i
think it's also funny you bring this up
because somebody was asking me today to
explain said can you who's david pac-man
what's the show about obviously an older
person is not watching their news on the
internet sure and the best thing i could
come up with was
imagine if alex jones wasn't bad
imagine if somebody was doing news and
commentary on the internet in an
independent way that wasn't just a grip
to try to sell you pills that turn you
red right like what if you had that and
and i'm you know that's one of the
reasons i went on tnt tyt one of the
reasons i was really happy to come here
yeah is because the solution sure isn't
good through the corporate media it's
through shows like this and by people
who are taking it seriously being
responsible well i appreciate that um
last thing i want to ask you about the
last time i was in the same room with
alex jones was years ago at a radio
conference called the new media seminar
which i don't even know if it exists
anymore and at the time my impressions
were he's playing a character my
impressions were that he got off the
stage after giving a sort of animated
but still kind of normal speech and he
said something like you know i could
have really freaked him out if i wanted
to and it seemed that he sort of
understood that the on-air persona was
not at all his sort of real life in the
last two years from everything i've seen
and read in interactions with jones out
in public that people have it's
increasingly seeming like the the
infowars alex jones is the the real guy
in your experience having been in the
room with him for as long as you were is
it is it a character or is that the real
alex jones you know that is a question i
have struggled with since the beginning
and at the start i thought i knew the
answer and i think that has changed over
time for me it's you
you see at first i was positive and i
still remain very positive that most of
the things he said for instance about
sandy hook he never believed he never
believed there were pictures of the
children still alive he never really
believed the school was shut down and
stocked and was a fake school i don't
think he believed any of that and so
there was a time that i really believed
that he was a sophisticated operator
completely detached from the things he
was saying but as we went through this
whole process i deposed him several
times as we went through trial i also
realized there is no off switch for
jones and there is a something about
spending every day wrapped in your own
bs that it starts to actually affect you
and there is a mindset jones i think
you're right when you say that he is
conscious of how his words appear to
people he and he is any and he wants to
try to control that but here we just saw
him in this trial
totally unable to turn off the freak
flag just for 10 minutes in front of
that jury and it really shows that
there's there's two sides of jones
there's a very very conscious
manipulator side to jones and then there
is a side where he is not really in
control of himself those two parts of
himself are at war and right now the
part of him that's out of control has
been winning handily for the last couple
years yeah out of control is uh quite
quite an understatement uh mark bankston
partner at farah and ball and lead
counsel in a number of defamation
lawsuits against alex jones and infowars
mark really a pleasure having you on
today
hey really pleasure being here if you
ever have legal questions and want to
talk about some more stuff please have
me back